So we're going to start with the mathematical definition of reduce.
Reduce has 2 inputs.
The 1st input is a set of elements, and we're going to assume they're in an array.
The 2nd input is a reduction operator that will operate on the elements in this array.
For example, we have a list of numbers here,
and we have a reduction operator of plus,
and the reduction operator will sum them all up.
Let's be a little more precise in terms of what operators we're going to support
with our parallel implementation.
Our operators need to have the following 2 characteristics.
The 1st is that the operators are binary.
The operator must operate on 2 inputs and create 1 output.
Plus is a binary operator, for instance.
Two, associative.
Associativity means that if we have 2 or more operations in a row,
a op b op c, the order of operations doesn't matter
as long as the order of the operands aren't changed.
To put it simply, a op b, take the result and op it with c,
needs to give you the same answer as b op c,
and then you op the result with a.
You should convince yourself that plus is an associative operator but minus is not.
Now, it's not immediately clear why we need this property
but we're going to see why in a few minutes.